when a new user signs up for your app  you could assign them with the same  grayed out default avatar that everybody  else gets but humans like to feel  special you are my friend you are  special one option is to generate a  random abstract pattern or better yet if  you know their name use their initials  and a random background color or you  might bring things to life with a random  robot or monster character or if you  know gender draw some random pixel art  for that human looks awesome but how do  i even program something like that the  answer is you don't there's a free and  open source tool called dice bear that's  already done all the hard work for you  just give it a theme and string as a  random seed and it will return you with  an awesome and unique avatar for every  user in your app